hello and welcome to this video this is
a new video and it's a rapid game only
chess I'm I've got the white pieces here
what am I going to do okay let's go on
idea three and playing it's 15 minutes
10 second increment I figured just go
with the official feeder rapid time
control I don't know I always think that
if you are online you can also go like
with a smaller increment like 15 plus 10
or something like 50 plus 5 because I
mean the 10 seconds in over the board
yeah you have to make the moves and
you're just quicker here with the pre
moves and everything online so I could
have gone for something a little bit
quicker maybe but I think we okay here
so um we have a more oxy point it's
always good to seen I'm always quite
happy with playing against it playing
with the pint against the accelerated
dragon I wanted to say okay so my
opponent here am Sh it's got a pretty
high rapid rating but it is kind of this
is probably like provisional and not so
many games um so Bishop g7 yeah guess
Bishop 3
Blackwell probably Castle I wonder if I
move autumn was that the best move water
possible I think he can maybe T gondii
for now with with the night and I cannot
check with the Queen you to Neji form
mmm didn't play this in a bit of a weird
way
okay probably it won't amount to much
and we get a normal position anyhow but
normally I play Bishop b2 instead of f3
f3 is interesting really forgotten the
precise move water here anyway
let's see how a.m. as ages responding
yeah I figured just post a rapid game
I'm currently thinking about different
things for the channel some more live
streams for example but there are many
things to consider there for example if
you do a live stream are you doing it on
Twitch are you doing it on YouTube it
gets kind of interesting if you see that
some of the twitch streams they have
tons of subscribers and I mean if I get
2000 subscribers like chess brought us
pretty much quitting everything else and
stream 24/7 I mean okay I'm going to
sleep ahead odd hour but yeah anyway
let's see it Queen b6 that's an
interesting news let's think about this
for a moment his threatening maybe night
I mean he's running on b2 and he's
threatening this come wrist with the
knight here like an IG 4 9 6 e 4 maybe
for example Queen d2 we will take Knight
XD form that is an important point
Knight C 2 I could play but then Queen
takes b2 and
yeah my night is hanging on c3 I don't
have Luke b1 or I can play Knight C -
Queen B - Knight f4 but it's got Queen
to e5
that's an escape square that b3 it's not
possible as the bishop is hanging so I
don't have all that many moves what I
can do is I can play Knight a form and
it's got Queen a5 Bishop d2 and then
it's going back this is not great
really not yeah
the Knight takes d4 Knight g4 threats
are annoying you could actually cover b2
tactically by a three but when I Queen B
294 it has no square it is threatening
those 94-94 business I think I have to
go 9a for not happy about it but
probably have to yeah who move order was
a little bit odd what I did him maybe
not great or him yeah the chick
yeah Bishop d2 and I have to play and
then he goes back and basically claims
that all my pieces are somewhat weird
with some justification okay 90 - Bishop
d2
yeah probably if you will drop back you
can play maybe Queenie five that's more
ambitious but it's not clear but it's
all that well placed in the middle of
the border
I'm 25 I probably what am i doing that
actually
hmm Bishop c3 hmm that looks odd I
probably would just move the light back
right b3 now he's going for it the more
ambitious means yeah so night 2 where C
2 B 3 even B 5 is not completely out of
the picture
Jim might be five I mean a six is kind
of debatable of that would would ever
help him for night 96 is annoying but
probably I just dropped back I mean it
looks a bit shaky on b5 this whole
configuration but where do I go see 2 or
b3 think after 93 I want to control a 5
the black queen does not have tons of
squares I'm really not in some cases um
actually I might threaten to trap it
for example Bishop is 6m there should be
six f4 is very close and f4 quintics a4
and then 93 takes take on g2 well at the
onliest game I think but it is it is an
escape b6 okay now that I did not expect
not sure what this actually does okay
okay it's rapid chess which means some
rapid moves should be played so let's
castle yeah b6 the felt is odd okay
this was the idea
mm yeah but she doesn't get all that
much pressure on their porn it's a
really weird queen I cannot really trap
it I mean 93 maybe I should try Knight
c3 but okay it's got a six for the Queen
yeah okay yeah I had to make some
awkward moves but it is just what it is
I'm I'm still enjoying all the space him
and he doesn't have anything great in
particular so I'm going to build up it's
a bit of a lazy move but I really don't
see what he's going to do okay school he
goes back okay maybe he prepares 95m
maybe anyway I need to play this just
sort my position yeah
Queen d2 and and everything then
ultimately Knight c3 to d5 is that is
the point
the the thing about b6m I'm always very
skeptical about this move and structures
like that because when I put a knight on
to d5 with white and that is almost
always going to happen the knight on d5
cannot be tolerated usually it has to be
taken and in case of a capture it just
yeah they're simply I'm this big hole on
c6 and a6 there are those big holes okay
95 is his idea know how to do that how
to handle that
okay 93 is the most obvious move in this
pollution can you take on c4 it doesn't
look like he should be able to do it but
Bishop takes
maybe he can actually do a 1093 Bishop
takes e4 Bishop takes Queen takes I have
night discoveries like 95 of course but
it's got Queen to a form it looks a bit
strange but I don't see how to I can
take on c6 then yeah rooks c6 rooks is
697 checking h8 takes takes maybe I'm
slightly better in this position I think
I am slightly better in this position
okay themselves this is desirable anyway
so let's do it
so Bishop takes Bishop takes Queen takes
95 and wherever the Queen goes a check
on c6 next rope chains yeah okay let us
say this is it's okay you know and she
doesn't have I don't know anything for
testing anyway let's see five maybe
unless he does take it okay okay so one
thing to do is definitely I mean I I saw
a line that seemed okay but this is a
stir this is a technically really risky
move so you have to check out if there's
anything else I don't see no so let's go
for me this time so the queen has to go
to a 4 B 5 so that C 6 has some
additional cover so here I am is there
something here maybe not really hey I
was thinking at some some way to deflect
the Queen but I don't think there is
okay so I have to take him the 7 fork is
giving me the regains the exchange
yeah there's no way now to check the
Queen
unfortunately so we have to I have to be
modest I says oh my god you don't you
don't see the chat I am yeah maybe I
should have put this wait
I could put this somewhere here I mean
everybody sees that it's rapidshare so
yeah I didn't think so much about the
layout and so anyhow um is there
anything better now and then taking it I
don't think so no so I was thinking I
have a slight edge here because the deep
pond is a weakness d5 is a weakness and
I'm also a bit quicker on the C file
I wonder what are you thinking about um
so my idea was like Queen d2 now it's
very very simple choice for Roxy one
lane it's got Queen a forum but then the
six is dropping is there a counter play
for Blackie like Knight e5 Knight c4 and
this is a counter play definitely
an interesting idea is look f2 en look
f2 to seek Him and to see to Oddie to
him
still this Queenie form will be somewhat
irritating not sure of 94 is really
great
another move that makes quite some sense
Bishop deform trying to trade
it's tough to decide 90 for the screen
c4 I don't like this all that much
let's make not terrible but doesn't
really doesn't really help
even though 94 Quincy 4 B 3 Quincy 3 now
the bishop haengsuk him so that it's not
really that fantastic
yeah okay black is still somewhat active
maybe it's clear that it's not terrible
from just that I felt I should be
somewhat better
yeah I'm trying again trading this
should be okay okay okay you could go
Knight to e5 but then actually Bishop c3
is an interesting choice m4 94 next yeah
my night my night it would like to be on
d5 M it's not really well positioned
there for example in this position if my
knight would be on c3 instead you can
actually paint that I always forget that
during the game if it would be on c3
this position would be excellent yeah
I'm basically plugging the C file yeah
cover b 5d 595 possible i would be great
okay maybe maybe later maybe later
but as he supposed to do Roxie ADA
probably no it's outside him yeah we'll
see eight probably
hmm yeah probably after rook c8 I will
invest a move on the back rank I like h3
or some onion okay yeah this was also
something that I've thought about I need
to I need to improve that in item the
nitrous this is a problem right so maybe
am i him anyway 494 next
there's also Knight d4 e to occur Knight
d4 e to F 45 on the way to the best
possible square
the bishop 1c3 also has the job show
simply they are plucked the CFR so that
there's no direct counter plane I just
spotted that maybe creature deform is
actually an idea queen deform with the
extremely extremely crude threat of f4
it could be a good idea actually I mean
now to see actually what does he do
against it
maybe Quincy form Quincy for attacking
my rook
24 is quite annoying okay that's one
idea
I also have this regrouping that I
mentioned with the night 94 he will
probably play Quincy form it detects a -
and it prepares to fire he wants to go
d5 here so let's do it
it's a bit odd but if it's good so if he
comes prints e4i I go look at the one
yeah that's almost almost mandatory okay
so yeah what do you want anything better
no don't think so
if he takes it io 90 form heading
towards b5 or again I teach wherefore
and so on now he only has this week d6
upon an aha I didn't think that was
possible
why is that possible so I take the pawn
what happens
okay after then then then he will take
on before I see and who thinks that our
discoveries okay okay
so and if I take it he will take with
the night
and okay let's say I play f4 f4 Queen
takes rook takes and then I'd see for
him
interesting I keep also but I can't
consider to just move the Queen away
actually like Queen to b3 or something
something like that
yeah still
not entirely clear what it does
I mean Queen d2 Queen d2 are basically
just threatening to take on d5
maybe it's got Queenie form
yeah it's not not really great
you don't have much with anything
I don't see a good move really that that
would keep anything
okay so how do I at least be safe here
yeah okay I'm not happy him it feels
like I don't have anything
yeah it's an extremely extremely fresh
account and so hard to evaluate this
opponent yeah Queenie for this mine does
the move I expect
now simply to countercheck their counter
check a two and establish material
equality if I check on d5 also moving
the Queen away gets 9 c4 into the game I
just spotted something that's not okay
not the end of the world I was always
thinking it okay like okay this is this
is something that worried me a little
bit a little bit
Kim I mean it's not threatening to take
but still I don't don't quite I don't
quite believe this should work
yeah maybe he was a kingi ADA yeah I
still cannot really believe that this ya
got all kinds of tricks
but yeah my thick ring is the BEC ring
is a problem
I think he will probably move the Queen
I'm playing Quincy free to make the rook
on mobile again let's just default pin
so let's say he goes Queen a form what
am i playing maybe look a 1m just
covering covering a 2
okay so can I move the rook this is a
good move to move it doesn't work okay I
only have a minute so it looks odd but I
just in case of Queenie 4 I'm covering
everything and only one it's not going
to get attacked
yeah
maybe maybe tonight she for in this case
man
now can you have to have to make a move
now black is very active he might he
might be very okay actually you know if
you get the 8 point I'm in trouble
yeah okay it is the thing
okay Nazi oneness 92 that's great
they're likely to be three is probably
winning for black extremely strange game
okay
just 30 seconds that's six doesn't work
this probably also doesn't work
I know he plays it
I can cannot move family and I can I
teach woo there's always might be three
very very annoying I'm not threatening
anything here
maybe knight c6 maybe 96 even then maybe
b3 just works like rook takes be too
okay it's a quick move I know this one
oh ah this was the thing whoa didn't see
that coming okay I didn't really
understand route 85 at all okay so he
threatens to take do you find f3
we should a seven rook a 5mm
look it's six no the check okay
threatening night takes before my
somewhat if not not really what is that
doing be free and I know let you take
the pawn
okay you know okay so let's say let's
have a look in the analysis board I
don't know I didn't really I think it's
kind of okay I know something some of it
is was obstructed you know it so let's
do the computer namely this thingy here
and see how yeah how well black played
actually made one inaccuracy okay
Oh to even
there was a really tough game I mean I
didn't play well with black played think
extremely well so we had the opening and
where's it here yeah this is a little
bit odd the M is Queen b6 Knight takes
c6 given here by stockfish well it's
actually possible but that something I
should have should have seen 94 is not
as good yeah cause even though I'm still
not very varied here because this is
such a sturdy structure it takes a quite
quite a number of rubbish moves to be
worse so yeah we should take Sephora's
it's a weird choice
yeah I'm better you quite but I didn't
play it well yeah
so 94 was stronger yeah and I was
actually more worried about this third
oh sorry the engine just claims this
this is right yeah that's definitely
true I did not consider this move and
now I am I have those ideas and also the
regrouping
yeah that's extremely good actually so
Bishop Defoe was wrong 95 I guess still
I mean ld5 is gaudium that's very strong
and again d4 is also very strong with
the point of King G idea
makes it complicated you're always
always difficult for me b5 I mean I'm
still okay here but I have to be very
precise Jake you know hh4 was the thing
Luke d1 okay okay
they didn't have much time left so this
this is supposed to be okay
yeah I mean if the engine gives zero
it's probably correct yeah fo I have
enough counterplay I with some some some
some checks or like each coin this is an
idiom simply like perpetually it's tough
to play okay each form takes and the 90
for him he I'm already struggling I know
you found 92 when the age five assists
of course not good but then the b-pawn
is just the beep one is just too strong
yeah they are not well played by me but
a very strong game here by my opponent
yeah thanks for watching the video
bye-bye